the heroes and villains of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe got snap happy in
Avengers endgame and one click of the
fingers created a potential problem for
a much-loved character Zoe Saldana's
Gamora Avengers and game directors Joe
and Anthony Russo have addressed the
green-skinned heroines fate but their
answer isn't as crystal clear as most
fans might hope after Avengers endgame
leaps forward five years to the year
2023 following the fallout of Avengers
infinity war the surviving heroes
concoct a plan to travel back in time
collect the Infinity stones ahead of
when Thanos took them then jump to the
present to equip their own infinity
gauntlets and resurrect their fallen
compatriots time travel the time heist
is successful despite a number of
hiccups along the way and the heroes who
were dusted an infinity war come back to
life to fight a final battle against
Thanos but those characters weren't the
only ones who returned to the MCU an end
game Gamora did too
but as the 2014 version of herself prior
to guardians of the galaxy and prior to
her death an infinity war she showed up
in 2023 after professor Hulk used his
Infinity Gauntlet to bring back the
dusted heroes and before Tony Stark
snapped his fingers to decimate panel
sent his army this raised a pressing
question if 2018 Gamora was killed when
Thanos sacrificed her to obtain the soul
stone in infinity war what happened to
2014 Gamora after Tony snap chatting
with business insiders Travis Clarke
Larusso said that there is an equal
chance that 2014 Kimura was spared and
Tony snap as there is the possibility
she died alongside Thanos and his
supporters
additionally Marvel fans will likely
have to wait until guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 hits theaters sometime in
the future to learn what really happened
to Gamora after Tony snapped
shutting down any speculation about
whether gamora's fellow guardians know
the answer Anthony Russo added that
star-lord is just as in the dark as fans
are Joe Russo then noted that he's
confident future films will answer that
question when Clarke commented that it's
up to guardians vol 3 director James
Gunn to fully unravel the mystery
Anthony agreed saying quote exactly
we've done our job it's not all that
implausible to think that 2014 Gamora
may have survived a climactic battle
between Thanos and the Avengers
despite her seemingly being
considered a part of bandulus
intergalactic army and not appearing in
physical form after Tony snap she does
however show up on a screen map in the
Guardians ship the Benatar at the end of
the film it seems evident that star-lord
and the rest of the team will embark on
a mission to locate Gamora and guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 considering how
pivotal to the franchise Gamora has been
it's only right that she would emerge
once more for the trilogy Endor if and
when Gamora returns in the third
guardians film
it's basically guaranteed that the
heroine will be the 2014 Gamora who
flashed forward in time and endgame the
Gamora who played a part in the first
two guardian movies and Avengers
infinity war is dead and cannot be
revived as endgame co-writer Christopher
Markus once explained when Gamora went
off that Cliff in infinity war the
Gamora from that time period died Joe
Russo confirmed elsewhere when speaking
about black widows death that non snap
deaths are permanent
he said the process is irreversible even
if you have returned the soul stone to
its original location you won't be able
to get the person back in fact it's not
really returning the stone more like put
it back properly the tribute soul for
the soul stone will forever be sealed in
that place
therefore Black Widow is gone forever if
Black Widow and Gamora experienced the
same demise that means 2018 Gamora is
gone forever as well past Gamora may not
be though and even if she was dusted
when Tony snapped his fingers there's a
chance she could return to life and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
end gamer coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]